The average thickness of ice in Antarctica
is about 1 mile.
The farther a cat falls, the better.
Cats are less likely to be injured if they
fall from greater heights.
When cats fall from 5 stories of higher they
reach terminal velocity and relax their bodies,
which slows them down and protects them from
the impact.
New Zealand will deny people residency visa's
if they too high of a BMI and there are cases
where people have been rejected because of
their weight.
Abraham Lincoln kept his important documents
inside his hat.
The world's most expensive phone number is
666-6666.
It was sold in 2006 for £1.5 million.
In ancient Rome, men found guilty of rape
had their testicles crushed between two stones.
When building the Golden Gate Bridge, the
lead structural engineer insisted on the installation
of a safety net even though its $130,000 cost
was deemed exorbitant.
Over the four years of its construction, the
net saved 19 men from certain death, who named
themselves the “Halfway to Hell Club”.
A physicist made his cat the co-author of
his scientific paper to avoid using “I”
instead of “we” throughout the paper.
An elephant's trunk has no bones but 40,000
muscles.
Cat kidneys are so efficient they can rehydrate
by drinking seawater.
The law enforcement in a town in Northern
Spain has ordered that all prostitutes in
the town wear reflective vests whilst working,
to avoid traffic accidents at night.
Before the holocaust Hitler gave the US, the
UK and many other nations the chance to take
in jewish refugees, but they all refused.
Every Panda in the world is on loan from China.
The logo of the New Zealand Air Force is the
Kiwi, a flightless bird.
After working out, it takes 5 hours for your
body temperature to return to normal.
India's “Go Air” airline only hires female
flight attendants because they are lighter,
so they save up to $500,000 per year in fuel.